all right uh chris we are 10 days away
from the 2019 draft nick bosa the ohio
state defensive end is expected to be
one of the early guys taken in round one
and we talked last week about the
the decision by bosa to stop
tweeting
on matters of politics he's a big
supporter of president trump his
explanation was i may end up in san
francisco but over the weekend
jemele hill formerly of espn now writes
for the atlantic and does some other
things she has a new podcast that debuts
i think today
she suggested that this ultimately is
about the locker room not where he plays
but where he is going to be working
whichever team it is that drafts him
because there and and
when you look at some of the things he
said you could make the argument there
may be a little bit of a racial slant to
some of the things that he's done on
social media i'm not saying that there
is but you can interpret it possibly as
being that way that can make it harder
for him to
properly mesh with his teammates in an
nfl locker room is that a legitimate
concern that a player should have if you
are getting close to that line
on social media with things that could
cause some of your african-american
teammates to raise eyebrows yeah well no
it what it's going to do
it's not like anybody's going to hate
nick bosa when if he gets drafted by the
49ers at number two and he walks in
there it's going to make guys though
look into the corner of their eye okay
you know
i'll say this and the nfl really guys
are judged by what they see and what
they do uh it's a very good environment
of not pre-judgment you know not judging
a book by its cover you know there
really is there's a lot of man's men in
the nfl where the guy comes in the
locker room and they just speak about
hey all i know is this guy's treated me
really well since he's been here i've
seen him work really hard since he's
been here you know and they try to go
from there i do think it's an
environment that's very much like that
but i do think at first with nick bosa
when you're on this conversation of
trump and yes the way a lot of
african-american players feel
disrespected and
by the way and actions of donald trump
at times yeah he's going to have people
looking out at the corner of his eye at
him at first
and maybe inspecting him in the locker
room a little bit more closely than the
normal rookie that comes to town and at
the very base level i mean again
you know i want to say with what jamil
hill says like i i you know again if
you're going to tweet these things out i
i do say like so you obviously think
something's wrong if you don't want to
own it and you're obviously a little
self-conscious of something that you're
putting out there to go
it's not really right because if it was
really right and you were like no i'm
good and i'm convicted i have conviction
about my tweets and what i think you
would just leave it out there but he
doesn't want to do that because i think
he knows it's dicey and
i certainly look at it as being a little
dicey
yeah i i think that uh
look if it's just about politics i don't
know why
you would
self-edit yourself as you would say
that's what struck me as odd last week
like why can't guys articulate their
political views regardless of what those
views are that's they
like richie incognito right you remember
richie incognito right i mean
he i believe was a very big trump
supporter kind of made it vocal but he
owned it and people in the locker room
lashawn mccoy everybody they liked
richie incognito you know so again you
know it's not
everybody does have their beliefs and
you can be respected that way within the
locker room uh but it is a little
awkward that he deletes it and i think
he is he's a young guy he's trying to
get on a football team he doesn't want
to cause any waves with an organization
over the locker room uh and you know
yeah it looks like he's backtracking a
little bit with this whole thing
yeah and and i i really do think that
you know that the idea of locker room is
is more
important than possibly ending up in san
francisco and wherever he goes there's
going to be a locker room that's going
to have to either accept nick bosa or
reject him and you know
curtailing opinions that could cause
some of your teammates at the nfl level
to say
what is
up with this guy and how does he really
feel about people of all backgrounds and
people of all races and does that become
an issue in a locker room and and and
look i i don't care what team you are at
the nfl level it is something to be
concerned about if you have that kind of
issue that is percolating between
players and causing possible
distractions real distractions that's a
real distraction if you have if you have
some sort of a disagreement in the
locker room and some sort of hard
feeling in the locker room because
there's a belief that there's a a white
player who has some sort of a racial
animus that's an issue and again i'm not
saying that he does but i could
understand based upon what you know when
i see what's out there and and i i
hadn't seen some of the tweets and i
they they don't cross the line but
they're close enough that it's fair to
wonder what's this guy
really thinking
and maybe that's why he is deciding you
know what the best thing for me is just
not even start down that path because i
don't want to inadvertently cross the
line and you know he still believes what
he believes that's the thing if you're a
teammate like just because you've kept
your mouth shut it doesn't mean you
don't believe these things yeah so i
still think he's already at a point
where he may have some damage to undo
chris no yeah i think so too uh you know
again and you know i don't i definitely
don't think nick bose is a racist or
anything like that i mean his dad played
in the nfl you know i've been around his
brother joey he's as cool as they come
his best friend on on the los angeles
chargers football team is melvin ingram
um you know hey does he have some
political views that i certainly don't
agree with when you're supporting donald
trump yes but i think more of the issues
that go on in the nfl locker room just
from people i you know players i know
around the nfl when i hear complaints
more than anything about this subject
it's more about the coaches that bother
the players more than anything because
as players you already feel like the
coaches look at you as property or a
piece of meat to a degree and you know i
think uh again what you've heard me say
before and what i think players can't
understand is you know coaches always
always are beating into players minds
you know be truthful be accountable work
hard don't blame others and do all those
things and they're trying to say that to
their position group but yet their
position coach supports donald trump and
i think the players look at that and go
man he's been disrespectful to
african-american players and all the
things you preach to me in the locker
room or in the meeting room that man
doesn't preach so i think they look at
some of their coaches a few of the guys
i've talked to and they just go you know
they they are like listen to what they
think about football and they're going
to take their coaching but i think on a
humane level there is a little
disconnect there with uh some some
players and and then their coaches on a
team
remember last year some tweets surfaced
from josh allen the bill's quarterback
from when he was in high school some
racially insensitive language and that
didn't cause a problem for him in the
locker room but i go back to 2013 the
riley cooper incident in philadelphia
chris where there was the racial slur
that was used and he was caught on
camera at a kenny chesney concert
and they really had
to work hard to get the locker room to
accept him mike vick who was represented
by the same agent who represented cooper
at the time kind of stood up for riley
cooper and and it helped him stay in
philly for a couple years but the eagles
cut him at 28 no one else ever signed
him after that the buccaneers gave him a
tryout i mean i i think that that there
is a line you can cross that makes you
radioactive and it's just not worth it
there's too many other guys out there
who can do what you do it's not worth
bringing a guy in there who is on the
wrong side of the line so again i i
agree with you nick bose is not on the
wrong side of the line but there was
enough there yeah that it makes it
understandable why he is putting a sock
in it when it comes to political
commentary on social media because if
you do cross that line you've got a real
problem for your football career you do
you definitely have a big problem and
you're right with the riley cooper thing
i i i still don't know why the eagles
stuck up for him i mean i would have
shipped his butt out of town so quick i
mean you have video of a guy getting
angry and talking and saying racial
slurs uh in a mean way
man i would have i would have gone to
the coach or the front office but get
his ass out of here right now see you
later sorry i said the a word but i
think we're all okay with that but that
to me is when you do cross the line and
he was just fortunate that he had just
enough support there in philadelphia to
buy himself a year or two
i you actually stopped and apologized
for saying the a word like you've never
said it before well i wasn't like you
haven't i didn't want to get you in
trouble
you ain't getting me in trouble if you
say it you're in trouble if you say it i
mean you talk about smoking weed all the
time you've dropped plenty of other
words that you know are close to the
line and you apologize for the a word
just continue your streak of not saying
the f word and we'll be fine thank you
let's take a break and when we return
here's what we're going to do if the
seahawks don't sign russell wilson to a
long-term contract today
who are the teams that should pick up
the cell phone device and call the
seahawks and say what would it take to
take russell wilson off your hands and
give us a chance to give them the
contract that you won't we'll discuss
that when pft life continues right after
this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports